tyler is in chicago
hey tyler welcome to the show hey how's
it going dr dean dave thank you so much
for taking my call
my pleasure how can we help
uh i'm in a crazy family and financial
situation right now that i want to get
some advice on
um about a year back my grandma gave my
wife and i
a gift of nine thousand dollars for a
home
uh telling us that it was our wedding
gift birthday gift
christmas gift forever so forth uh we
were grateful and we offered to pay her
back
um eventually as soon as she gave gave
the gift to us but she told us don't
worry about it
that she was so happy to help us out
fast forward a year
she's been asking us recently how we
were doing financially
just weird weird questions for her she's
she's not that intimate usually
and come to find out she just wanted to
see when she could ask us for that money
back that she told
us was a gift um she
wrote us a letter in the mail saying
that she wants all the money back
plus interest and in the letter never
mentioned that
it was a gift to us so now in her eyes
we her twelve thousand dollars
um we have paper yeah yeah so we have
paperwork
um that she filled out to get tax exempt
from like because it was a gift and we
just don't know what to do right now
she's done stuff like this before to my
parents
i thought that my wife and i were the
exception but uh come to find out we're
not
um she's also saying things about her
will
that we're in her will and the money
that we're going to be paying her back
monthly is going to go towards quote
unquote
our future home which is
it it's just a mess and how old your
ground you don't know what to do
how old is your all right she she's 64.
okay what's your household income
um after tax is about 70. okay
so you said you've got a payment plan
have you already worked something out
with her
no we we've been very vague in
communication um
i didn't want to agree to anything
before i talked to
someone who could help okay i i
dave i'm gonna love to hear your way on
this and i'm
tyler i'm answering you but i'm also
leaning towards dave as i as i ask this
question as i answer this question
it sounds like dave he's gonna choose
between
nine thousand dollars or twelve thousand
dollars
and or a relationship that's gonna
ripple through his entire family
and it sounds like they've been through
this before it sounds like he has a
decision to make whether he wants to go
to war with grandma
or he wants to write her a letter back
and say i'll come up with some sort of
payment plan
and wash his hands at that and learn
this lesson and never make this mistake
again
[Music]
beware grandmother has big teeth right
yeah it does yeah yeah she does there's
a story
written about this yeah yeah exactly
and it hurt she told us a gift and said
don't ever worry about paying it back
that it's
you know it's her gift to us
is she mentally ill yeah
or is she just uh or is she just a liar
she's a liar she's been diagnosed as a
narcissist and
and a liar okay so the the thing right
now
where is the money
yes i wish i would have listened to you
guys sooner but
so can you write a check for nine
thousand dollars
oh right now um we're building up our
emergency fund we have about
5 000 in the bank okay
yeah and my wife she works at a gym and
we live in illinois
and i mean if kovid flares up she's
going to be out of her position yeah
and she was for a while already yeah so
tyler one thing
dave's about to answer here one thing i
want you to put down
like quit carrying around what she told
you a year ago that
you're trying to balance those two
realities and the new reality that you
have
is a letter it's a demand letter for
twelve thousand bucks i don't see any
way in the world legally or morally or
otherwise that
you over twelve thousand dollars um i
don't think that you
i think legally or morally you or any of
this money um
i just think there's a broader family
conversation that you need to engage in
yeah so yeah you do not morally owe her
a dime
and so you would be you would be in your
rights to just get on the phone with her
and say grandma
you told us that this was a gift
we have paperwork that shows that it's a
gift and now you're reneging on that
and that's not okay you're misbehaving i
love you
but i don't love this behavior and i'm
not going to pay you
because i don't owe you that's one
option
now you and i both know what's going to
happen when you do that
oh for sure yeah she's going to be mount
vesuvius
because she likes to pull people's
strings and when they don't dance at the
end of her string
she has a little fit right
absolutely this is the pattern that
you've watched when you were growing up
with your parents and her
this is 100 percent what this woman is
okay
and so we can predict fairly accurately
what she's going to do
now is that what you want to do or do
you want to just give her
12 000 or 9 000 or whatever as fast as
you can
and i wouldn't set up a payment plan i
just save up some money and ignore her
until then and then write her a check
for 12 grand
and then uh but i here i kind of think
when you give her 12 grand you're
probably going to get a letter that goes
oh yeah i forgot about the other
thousand you still owe
yeah that's right yeah or building up
interest from now until i pay it back
yeah or more or she changes the interest
rate because there was never an agreed
interest rate because it was not alone
right so she makes crap up as she goes
in order to get her
to in order to keep her hooks in the end
of the puppet
and so um i don't know if you're ever
going to make her happy i know
so i'm not sure paying her is going to
work
i am sure not paying attention
yeah so it's up to you you just you got
to kind of play this out and go am i
willing to have her angry with me
or do i want to give this a shot and be
rid of her
and obviously we're doing no more
business transactions with this woman as
long as she breathes
oh absolutely not we have learned that
we have learned that lesson the hard way
in either case so you guys just got to
decide which one
but i think we can predict that if you
just confront her and just
call it what it is it's a lie it's a lie
and you told me this and i'm going with
what you told me and we're not going to
pay you
and you don't have you can't pay her
right you don't have the money well i'm
not no
no no it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if you had 50 000 bucks in the
bank right
you know it's morally wrong she's a
manipulator
a narcissist a liar and so do you want
to
what level do you want to have a
relationship with her and do you want to
attempt
to try to spend 12 thousand dollars for
that for that
option right and that's really all it is
because it has nothing to do with the
actual transaction
it's got to do with power and control
yeah this the actual transaction that
occurred is very clear
in your mind and you it and i think it
is
exactly what happened too because you
were so able to articulate the details
of the transaction and so i believe i
believe that
your view of this is not crazy um so
i'd also advi i'd also advise colin
sitting down with his parents if he
hasn't already
and saying how have you all handled this
in the past what's grandma gonna do here
um and they may have circled back and
said we told you not to take that money
so if you were to do this again someday
or if someone listening has a similar
situation
make if you think grandma is a suspect
her
end game may be not what it appears when
you're offering the new young couple
that just got married the new
newlyweds nine thousand dollars why nine
anyway
that's a random out of ten but um
round up geez but um anyway but but yeah
if you think that's the case i would
have her
put in writing that it is a gift because
we
know her track record of having changed
her story and then when it comes up i
just send her that back
that's right and in that if i had that
in this case there would be no question
and it i can't help but think that
rattling around in their minds is if we
draw a line here
usually people who operate like this may
have substantive
accounts other places maybe in a will
somewhere i don't really care well
that's what i'm saying
i want i want people to draw integrity
lines and say i'm not going to take that
i'm not going to take that burnt money
anyway
right i don't really care if i'm in the
will we're going to hold down to our
integrity here we're going to say no
take me out of the world that's fine
that's right please take me out of the
will
because i don't really want to negotiate
with the other crazy relatives
that's exactly right this is the dave
ramsey show